hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play labyrinth now
this is something that's confused me for
a while because I people were telling me
left and right go and play labyrinth
play labyrinth and I was like I already
played labyrinth you can check my videos
just right here in fact everyone who
emailed me like play labyrinth oh I sent
him the link to the video where I did
play a game called labyrinth but
apparently this is another game called
labyrinth that's new so my mistake
I guess Sara now this is gonna be
labyrinth B and the other one was
labyrinth a I'm pretty sure there's more
games called labyrinth but anyway let's
see what it's about I don't know it
actually had a custom installer so I
can't tell you what engine it is it
might actually blue is now what I was
expecting
nice torch created by haha burn you
[ __ ] the altar has something something
is missing
additional it needs a key the skull keep
it out of the blue Luna the screaming
their cries whispers they will find you
Hey look their skull okay so I am slow
there we go it's really slow what is
this exclamation point no quest steak
nice lighting system I guess I'm not I
couldn't tell you what engine this is
I'm not that big of a nerd but uh looks
good so far I'm actually kind of
impressed damage [ __ ] you up dead
[Music]
excuse me who what the [ __ ] what what
happened where did he come from they're
gonna find me no kidding he was right
there this isn't exactly a good hiding
spot okay so he was right there how did
he get there I didn't even see him till
he was charging me guess it got a height
or run I can't really do much I wholly
up here ha ha [ __ ] ha ha what are you
gonna do now oh I'm in a cupboard do
some surgery Tunnel was this survived
another attack it must have been the
beasts of legend what's wrong with me Oh
heard it coming and turned off my torch
no use it knows I'm here it's too fast
to outrun but it can't fit in the
tunnels that's the beasts of legend
don't look very beasty looks pretty
wimpy to me jeez popped up out of
nowhere though her car
Oh Oh so ronery okay now I go
you didn't hear [ __ ] oh look it's a
stretcher was that paper airplane it is
I was just guessing did not think that
was actually a paper airplane these look
fun why hey why those puddle collapse
didn't well how am I gonna get back oh
maybe this was it Oh baby oh yeah I ran
wait did I know Flint
I've got Flint's what do they do can i
light these candles or is this torch
just everlasting
now where's douche McGillicuddy Gila
Cuddy McGee oh that's a flint not a
paper airplane
oh okay never mind am I my apology you
know a five flips okay so I've got the
map but the map goes away and rebuilds
as you're walking I am now walking in
the wall apparently see another hidey
hole I don't know what the objective is
I think I need to find a key or a skull
or something I'm not sure Eliseo oh hey
gimme gimme
oh I can't help more than five now you
tell me Sam - would hey [ __ ] are you
over there beasts of legend look pretty
humid for being a beast they call me the
Beast
what is that oh hello what is this uh I
just pissed in the phone to relieve
myself apparently why what was that ah
that is a piece of legend though they
was big okay the other guy was the can
whip that thing was huge cow dick I can
sprint while crawling good golly that
thing was gigantic what was that holy
baloney my goodness
I don't know what that was but I didn't
[ __ ] out run aah not fair gopher you get
away huh
got the skull get back you [ __ ] I got a
skull ha ha
Oh screw you guys screw you guys I
didn't know the little guy could fit in
the hole to run
I haven't I don't even know that guy
popped up outta nowhere I got the skull
but I didn't even now a chance together
I guess I could call through the tunnels
again that guy was right okay then next
time once I get the skull I'll go
through the tunnels again because I
don't want to be caught out in the open
with that guy whatever was that a minute
or a minute are see is this randomizer
who hello hi I see you oh no he's
chasing me I'm not worried about you I'm
worried about that other thing
hell it was God he was so big big strong
it's just grubby hi hey no fair you let
me do it oh this is familiar wait
okay the levels are not randomized hi
what are you doing why are you even
working for that [ __ ]
hey you're injured get out of here don't
cares about you go away stop hobbling
hobble somewhere else I cannot run fast
for anything cheese okay I know the
beasts of legend is just beyond that
corridor whew is that a skull of legend
it is it is a skull of legend hi you're
an [ __ ]
do you know that have I told you that
already yeah you're an [ __ ] okay so
if I go this way I should be able to get
back up at stairs and then I'll get the
hell out of here maybe or maybe I need
more skulls I don't know goodness
gracious
some people see screaming oh goodness
haha I win did I won that one
[Music]
haha suck on that Minotaur I did it I
didn't expect the game to end that
quickly from what the map looked like it
looked like there was a ton of other
stuff in there that I could have been
but I mean I guess the location of the
skull is randomly generated or something
like that be either way that was really
good but really good I wonder who made
this
it didn't say there's no credits or
anything so I mean that was I was really
impressed by that that was well-made I
mean you know I can't really criticize
because it's not you know like an indie
title well it's an indie title but I
mean it's like like legit work when in
this so I got another bad to say about
it everyone try it for yourself
download link is in the description
below so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
it looks like a jump jump
[Music]
you know you know a job job you know the
trader thing
ja wohl yeah jump jump you can see the
relation oh shut up